kevin you ready to hop on it looks like
you're at work i can't tell if you can
hear me or not
yeah just give me a thumbs up yeah
you're good okay so i'm going to pull
kevin in because he's got something here
for us
hey are you doing rich is the audio good
yeah you're fine yeah what do you got
for us tonight thank you
all right how are you doing rich how are
you doing jonathan uh great yeah i'm not
working so
just excuse the happiness with the video
but uh i can
the type of job i'm doing i can talk and
work at the same time
a little bit of background story on me
actually uh so i used to be in the air
force
i was married recently divorced uh
same with uh the last gentleman's name
like when i was
an aircraft mechanic and i am father of
two
daughters and i had both of my daughters
while in the military
so one of the things that drew me to
leave the military or i should say
finish my contract
was that my daughter was born shortly
before i was deployed
and one of the things i i don't even
wish my worst enemy is that the feeling
you get when you come back from a
deployment you've missed
the first year of your childhood and
through your child's childhood
and the child doesn't recognize you so
at that point i realized well i need to
finish out my contract and i don't want
to
you know i want to become a father well
fast forward
to the end of my contract and i was
putting my ex-wife through school
uh and nursing she obtained her
bachelor's in nursing and the plan was i
discussed with her
this is back in 2014 was that you know
can we
sustain on you working because you'll be
able to be making more than what i did
in the military while i find some work
and we try and i transition out
and by this time my second daughter have
been born they have been planning to
deploy me and those in the chat that
know about the military
the u.s military at least is that
typically once you're in the separation
process
within less than a year they won't
deploy you or they'll cancel any
deployments if you don't re-enlist
so with that being in play and the same
2014 was the year prior to me separating
my second daughter had been born
um and we went ahead and
separated out she got a job in nursing
and
just you know the whole rig of meru how
it goes with most people you know you
hear the same story over and over again
where it's like it's a sexist marriage
there's a tension there's a disrespect
to nagging it's the whole modern woman
thing
right and let's just speed it up a bit
to recently times and more
to what i'm trying to build up to is
that
my two daughters right i'm a hispanic
background
and i don't know how to say this without
being outside of being politically
correct
but my first daughter you can tell she's
my daughter skin tone
attitude behavior everything second
daughter
she came out you know mostly white and
doesn't really
behave in the same manner i do but you
know i still own her as my daughter my
name's on the birth certificate and
everything
i come to find out that this was maybe a
few weeks ago so
she was friends with someone in the
nursing college and i was friends with
her husband
and they divorced shortly after they
graduated
and then he knew some people at the
college and they all wanted they were
um for some clarification this is in
florida
tampa bay area it was university of
south florida
so they all went to usf and
i found out that she married well she
found she married
last month to somebody that i didn't
really approve of i don't even met the
guy
and they she he knew her back in 2014
during the year i was separating also
the same year that my second child was
born
and everything starts like i haven't
done a paternity test yet but i'm just
like i don't even know what
if i even should at this point but it's
just something
she's seven years old seven years old
and the first daughter
so what do you recommend when you got a
seven year old and you're questioning
paternity john
well you've already acknowledged
paternity
and once you do that i don't know where
you're located now or
are you i don't know if you're still in
florida or what jurisdiction you're in
florida
yeah you want to talk to a local lawyer
i don't know if you'd want to open that
can of worms
if she recognizes you especially if she
recognizes you as her father
uh but that that's a tough situation
the time to uh question paternity is
right at birth
before you're on the birth certificate
get a dna
test it's usually free or less than 150
they just swab both your cheeks and with
99.99
uh certainty they could tell whether or
not you
are the the parent and no one has to
have their blood drawn or anything
anymore
uh that is the time now there are guys
in your situation that
you know at this point seven years
though you know she you recognized
as her as her dad you know you've been
taking care of her you paid child
support
no actually i mean again i don't want to
run the
segment don't you want them yeah no it's
okay it's just that i'm actually
you can consider me in the single digit
percentile of men
that's again that's a whole another
story but it's to try and condense it
down is that i
recently um just graduated my
associate's degree i was using the gi
bill which is a
it's a stipulation in the military that
if you once you serve a certain amount
you can get um
three years of benefit and she convinced
me back a few years ago
said hey you know once you quit your job
i'm a mechanic by trade
and um and just go and finish your
engineering degree that he started you
know back in high school
we were supposedly i guess you'd call it
high school sweethearts
um and i said sure okay that sounds like
a good idea you know you're making
way more than i did she was making like
ten dollars an hour more than i did at
the time and i said all right well let's
go ahead and do this i mean i'm gonna
get a monthly stipend to a housing
stipend and it'll work out
um we'll get by you know we had some
debt and it'll work out and so far you
know
about a year and ish but yeah about a
year or so in
um this is october 2019 you know the
you know i mean again the marriage side
of the thing started falling apart
probably within the last three years of
the marriage i was married for 10 years
and you know the whole thing it's like
hey i don't know i don't want to be with
you anymore
it's like again it's like it's funny
because if you follow the other you know
manosphere the redbull content on the
platform
it's you know i didn't see it back then
but you know obviously force in
hindsight is 2020
is that you know the timer started well
the timer probably started back in 2014
when she said oh my security's going
away he's leaving the military what is
this like what is this
you know what are these shenanigans um
yeah so it's just
uh so yeah that got sprung on me i don't
again
like i said i consider myself in the
probably in the decimal percentile just
because
i had a um she earned more than i did
she i didn't have a degree because in
the court at least down here
from my experience the florida
courthouse they consider earning
current earnings current earning
potential so like if you have degrees
i didn't have one i had a fema a young
female judge
she was in her late 30s and at the at
the um
at the hearing she even said i see
you're not pursuing child support um you
are entitled to it would you like me to
grant it and me being my dumb self
especially with all of the
the torment she's trying to put through
she's trying to commit like
psychological acts to me through the
kids um that's again that's a whole
other story
but again i just with everything being
stacked against me i should have i could
have taken half of her retirement i
declined it i could have taken child
support i declined it the only thing i
took
was the alimony well that was just
enough to just to get me out of the
house
guys don't don't be a nice guy when it
comes to family loft
nice guys get destroyed in family law
and they and they lose leverage and they
lose opportunities
um and it's very very hard to get him
back once it's been awarded to somebody
else
uh i don't know jonathan i mean like do
you want to say something about that
uh in terms of custody once that's been
awarded no in terms of being a nice guy
like you know he forfeited um
you know an opportunity to get alimony
you know as an example or
or child support but like you know like
guys tend to
do that like chivalrous stuff because
they're like ah you know i want to be a
nice guy and try to make this thing wrap
up and go away but
nice guys get destroyed in family court
man you could always take it and then
change your mind and say i i want to
agree to reduce it
especially since now if you were
marrying
uh a very very wealthy woman and you
said to her you know what
i don't want anything from you i'm i'm
moving into this woman's house whatever
that's different uh so i'd want to know
more about it but
yeah i mean you want to try to keep the
peace but you have to take care of
yourself too
and it's a personal decision uh
so hopefully you're back on your feet
and you're focused and doing all the
right things
because that's really absolutely this
past year and a half was probably the
worst i i accrued like thirty thousand
dollars in credit card debt the pandemic
really put a
a massive dent in my life um but again i
i still consider myself extremely lucky
i mean i know there's guys that
sorry i just because i'm just thinking
about some of the guys that i've known
that you know they have
self-deleted uh just much worse yeah
situations they've lost everything yeah
i lost the house yeah i you know i got
stuck with all the debt
at the end of the day i have 50 percent
custody of my children i see them half
of the week and i actually get to pick
them up this wednesday and i get you
know it's just
i'm still involved in their life and and
she's been doing things
yeah she's been doing things like
putting things in their head like my
oldest came up to me last month like oh
daddy i only want to see you
um you know maybe only two weekends a
month and i'm like where did this come
from
like i know where it came from right
it's like
and it's just like and then she brought
it up again through text a few weeks ago
and i'm like i'm
this is out of the discussion the
parenting plan you know it explicitly
says
50 50 and these are the days and it's
just i don't understand you're trying to
get them to
spend more time with you and now and
like she's with the stepfather
changes the kids get older doesn't it
jonathan like because they become
teenagers and they can
decide where they want to spend i mean
that's the case here in canada anyway i
mean
you know by about between florida is
very similar yeah
sort of the same thing down florida they
have um
there's no statute for the age actually
uh
if you look up for florida child cases
in terms of i mean there's
50 50 leading up to 12 13 and all of a
sudden at 13 14 she's like yeah you know
what mom's closer to the scroll mom's
closer to all my friends
i think i wanna stay there more you know
sometimes kids
get ahead no they could do that right
now in florida uh the thing is that the
court decides the way the law is written
is if the child is mentally mature
enough to
know that they're aware of the decision
they're about to make and there was a
case for a nine-year-old and there was a
case
for the nine-year-old there was a case
against an 11 year old so it's that's
what i'm saying there's conflicting
cases
but it all depends on the judge it all
depends on the child
it's that they they're more specific on
the case here than a broad sweeping law
right all right kevin thanks for chiming
in and sharing your story man
good luck with everything no thank you
i'm just i'm glad to get the word out
and to know that you know there are guys
out here that make it out alive so
appreciate it thank you for bringing on
the platform
that's great wow a tough situation for
sure
yeah as uh moth pointed out in the the
live chat this guy
uh there's a guy who wasn't letting the
bs keep him down he's a real soldier
yeah yeah it's good for him he's got a
great life ahead if he could
keep that attitude stay focused so good
for him
you